[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'ai envie ce soir de vous raconter une
histoire qui m'est arrivé il ya quelques
mois je participais une réunion avec des
décideurs élus architectes promoteurs
immobiliers et comme souvent dans ces
instances de décision j'étais la seule
femme je vous le précise parce qu'au
moment des présentations un célèbre
architecte est venu me demander si
j'étais la femme d'un des élus à côté de
qui j'étais en train de m'installer
tout est dit comme si la présence d'une
femme à cette réunion ne pouvaient
s'expliquer que de cette manière être la
femme deux comme s'il était impossible
d'imaginer qu'une femme puisse avoir une
compétence sur la ville
cette histoire me fait dire que les
femmes des 6,2 sont si peu nombreuses
que les hommes s'en étonne lorsqu'elles
sont présentes et l'urbanisme ne déroge
pas à cette règle
mais l'absence de femmes dans les
instances de décision pour la
construction de la ville n'est pas
qu'une question d'égalité d'accès à
l'emploi des responsabilités c'est aussi
un problème pour l'aménagement de nos
espaces publics est un enjeu majeur pour
rendre nos villes plus égalitaire alors
vous parlez des espaces publics et leur
partage équitable ce soir c'est vous
faire comprendre qu'ils décident
l'aménagement de ces villes et comment
sont pensés les espaces publics que nous
pratiquons la domination masculine est
présente partout dans la construction de
la ville
prenons quelques exemples seuls 2% des
rues françaises portent un nom de femme
sur les 302 stations que compte le métro
parisien la station louise michel est la
seule à rendre hommage à une femme
et depuis la création du grand prix de
l'urbanisme il ya bientôt 30 ans seules
deux femmes ont obtenu cette distinction
contre 23 hommes
je vous propose de prendre une seconde
pour regarder le visage de ces deux
femmes
autant vous dire que j'ai démarré mon
activité professionnelle sous les
meilleurs auspices en tant que femme
urbaniste et paysagiste dans un milieu
d'hommes qui décidez de tous sur la
ville sauf peut-être d'une chose ils
avaient l'amabilité de me laisser la
prérogative du choix des fleurs pour
décorer les espaces publics et cette
gouvernance d'hommes n'a pas beaucoup
évolué depuis cette époque où j'étais
jeune urbaniste époque pas si éloigné
tout de même pour preuve seulement 14%
des maires élus aux dernières élections
sont des femmes
mais parlons maintenant de la
fabrication de nos villes et la
conception des espaces publics
la grande majorité des concepteurs de la
ville sont des hommes
ces hommes ont créé nos lieux de vie et
ont imprimé leur marque sur la fabrique
de la ville avec parfois des résultats
mitigés
j'en ai fait l'expérience en travaillant
en tant qu urbanistes dans des villes
comme evry et cergy pontoise en banlieue
parisienne
la création de ces villes nouvelles a
été décidée par des hommes qui
représentait l'état dans les années
soixante à grands renforts de moyens
survol de l'île de france en hélicoptère
pour localiser ces villes
démultiplication des schémas directeurs
pour enfin désigné des hommes de l'art
qui mettrait en oeuvre ces villes dans
une volonté de modernité alors en
arrivant dans ces villes
j'ai cherché les marques de cette
modernité prenons l'exemple du centre
ville ce qui tenait lieu de centre était
en fait une immense dalle difficilement
accessibles par des escaliers déserté
par les commerces mal éclairé très peu
de vent pour s'asseoir et ne parlons pas
des espaces paysagers qui était pour le
moins inexistant le résultat de ce type
de conception est préjudiciable pour
tous mais les premières victimes en sont
les femmes car elles ne s'y sentent en
sécurité
elles n'ont pas accès à tous ces espaces
publics et parfois ne font que les
traversées 40% des femmes renoncent à
fréquenter certains lieux publics plus
d'une francilienne sur trois dit avoir
peur dans son quartier le soir contre
moins d'un francilien sur 10
et rien n'est fait pour que les jeunes
femmes se sentent à l'aise dans ces
espaces puisque les trois quarts des
budgets publics destinés aux loisirs des
jeunes profite exclusivement aux garçons
je pense au city stade et autres
skatepark nos espaces publics ne
tiennent pas leurs promesses
par définition ils devraient être
accessibles à tous et ce n'est pas le
cas le problème c'est que les
professionnels de la ville continue à
planifier pour certains hauts lieux
planifié avec eux et c'est ainsi que les
femmes se retrouvent à faire partie du
décor au lieu de faire partie des
acteurs
je vous donne l'exemple des réunions de
concertation auquel je participe ou bien
souvent les projets sont présentés à
titre informatif devant un public
clairsemé et majoritairement masculin en
agissant ainsi nous ne parvenons pas à
faire remonter la vie de tous et de
toutes
alors ignoré l'interaction entre genre
et villes risquent de rendre la ville
toujours plus inégalitaire
mais cette prise en compte ne se décrète
pas elle se construit étape par étape
avec l'envié de faire changer et de
faire évoluer la manière dont on pense
david en 2010 je me suis lancé dans
l'entrepreneuriat avec cette ambition de
bousculer cette profession et ses modes
de pensée je souhaitais changer la
manière dont on fabrique la ville et la
manière même dont les acteurs
travaillent pour créer nos lieux de vie
ça n'a pas toujours été facile ça
continue à ne pas l'être mais depuis
quelques années tous les acteurs de la
ville sont appelés à faire évoluer leurs
pratiques professionnelles parce que la
ville est en pleine mutation et pour
répondre aussi à l'injonction du
développement durable si ces pratiques
sont effectivement en train de changer
force est de constater que la prise en
compte du genre reste marginal dans la
création des nouveaux quartiers
elle est très souvent négligé quand elle
n'est pas oublié et pourtant ce sont des
millions de mètres carrés qui vont
bientôt sortir de terre en ile-de-france
avec l'occasion d'accueillir de nouveaux
habitants de nouvelles infrastructures
de transport
et combien de nouveaux espaces publics
alors autant d'opportunités pour que
cette question l'égalité soit au centre
de nos réflexions
nous avons une responsabilité sociétale
en tant qu urbaniste et professionnels
de l'aménagement pour faire que cette
question d'un usage équitable de la
ville soit au coeur de nos
préoccupations
alors que devons nous faire pour y
parvenir
c'est d'abord une sensibilisation nos
décideurs aussi bien les élus locaux
nationaux que les acteurs privés qui ont
un rôle de plus en plus prépondérant
dans la production de la vide
je pense aux promoteurs immobiliers
investisseurs et d'autres encore il
s'agit aussi et surtout d'éveiller la
conscience citoyenne car ce sont les
usagers vous moi qui faisons la pratique
de la ville et qui demain pourront faire
valoir cette question l'égalité comme un
enjeu électoral
nous devrions également nous inspirer de
vivre qui agissent pour promouvoir cette
question de l'égalité vienne en autriche
a depuis plus de 15 ans pris en compte
la place de la femme dans la ville elle
a été jusqu'à créer au sein de ces
services municipaux
une équipe dédiée en charge d'intégrer
la dimension du genre dans toutes les
étapes de ces politiques publiques en
france d'autres villes ont su se saisir
de cette question comme les villes de
rennes ou paris qui a tout juste un an a
édité un guide référentiel genre et
espaces publics qui propose des pistes
d'action pour agir sur le sentiment de
sécurité et l'établissement d'un usage
égal dans nos espaces publics
nous devons enfin changer nos méthodes
de travail
il est temps de travailler avec une
concertation qui fasse que les habitants
sont simplement invités à réagir à un
projet qui leur est présentée comme je
vous le montrer dans les précédentes
illustration nous devons inventer de
nouvelles méthodes plus inclusive qui
placent l'usagé au coeur de la
conception et c'est de cette manière que
nous arriverons à faire émerger la
diversité des besoins de tous
depuis trop longtemps l'urbanisme a
ignoré la place de la femme dans la
construction de la ville
alors il est temps que l'ensemble des
acteurs qui contribuent à aménager nos
espaces publics prennent leurs
responsabilités que nous changions nos
pratiques et nos mentalités pour que la
ville devienne enfin un espace d'égalité
réelle
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]